there was this girl who was two years
ahead of me and she had
huge boobs in high school and she would
go to the trainer before and they would
duct tape her boobs down
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who once wore zebra striped
leggings and a ramones t-shirt on a
class trip to the white house elise
morales
and with us today guys we have a writer
and tv producer whose book
notes from the bathroom line humor art
and low grade panic from 150 of the
world
of the funniest women in comedy which i
may or
may not have contributed to is out now
but before all of that she was a
graduate of the university of chicago
laboratory school it's amy solomon
hi that is an amazing outfit for the
white house it
uh i wanted i wanted george w bush to
know that i didn't [ __ ] respect him
and i was gonna show up in his house
looking however i wanted to look
incredible there's a famous story we
went on a family
tour of the white house you know in like
the 90s and
um my sister asked if this portrait of
george washington was barbara bush
oh no
oh that rocks
and she's probably in zebra leggings who
knows that
is very how old was she she was pretty
little we were
we were little okay that's like that's
even
like that's even worse because that's
just pure like she
genuinely was just like isn't that
barbara bush yep 100
the hair is not that different it was
fair it was fun and
and like to i don't know the style
of a president in the 1700s can be very
similar to the style of like a
republican woman in 1992
like ruffle shirts that's like a big
area in
just like white pulled back curls
kind of i see where she was coming from
with that totally
anyway uh did you go on any major class
field trips in high school
we did we did an eighth grade dc
trip that was huge so did because you
went to
you grew up in chicago so was that like
an overnighter
yeah it was like that was like the like
you went for like a week
right so my school we'll get into all
this but my school was k through 12.
okay only a hundred kids in a grade so
these tr i mean that seems insane to me
to try to organize but it wasn't like
you know they could everyone could fit
on one plane it wasn't that crazy
yeah that makes sense so that the eighth
grade dc one was like
the big one for like you know monday to
friday all the monuments
riding around on the tour bus thing oh
and socially that
must have just been an incredible thing
my
uh when i grew up out in la my school
did do a dc trip
in fifth grade so it was like we were a
little young
for there to be like any shenanigans
yeah that's a long flight it was
it was um but in eighth grade i imagine
like the romance the drama
i can i i can only imagine big time
someone got sent
home for going in the water at the fd or
fdr memorial they like went in the
fountain situation
yeah yeah you're not supposed to do that
you know those
definitely not not an fdr i love him um
that you know how those hotels like
they're like an atrium hotel and there's
like almost like
a corridor inside but it all looks down
i'm not describing is this the watergate
like that i think so yeah yeah do you
all stay at the watergate
yeah just for real historical
significance
um no but it was like yes you could like
if you were out of your room you could
see people like across the way oh my god
that just upped the intrigue even more i
don't know
and there was so many rules yeah i think
like two or three people got sent home
there was definitely some
shenanigans and did you get to like room
with friends
yeah so it was like you picked your pals
and it was like four
to a room and it was like big sleepover
vibes i mean
so the excitement of that is
unparalleled like to be able to have a
sleepover
with your friends that's at a hotel i
mean
unbelievable i also think it was like
two beds for the four people they were
just like
oh yeah and now as an adult i'm like
i want my own room yeah
i would never sleep over at someone's
house i want to be at my house i know
seriously yeah that was uh wow that was
a juicy time
yeah i mean that sounds that sound that
is the stuff that like a lizzie mcguire
made for tv special
would be about like they would be like
the washington dc
trip special and it would all go down
and like her and gordo would maybe kiss
it would certainly be teased that they
were gonna kiss
absolutely yeah no that was a it's such
a rite of passage
i feel like i know most people i know
went on like a dc trip
yeah when you're there you see a million
other schools on their tour buses too i
feel like there were like common weeks
to go do it
you know well yeah and then like once i
moved to outside the dc
area there's like trips within trips
that you do so it's like we went to see
the white house and then
senior year there was a capital hill
trip that i went on with my two
boyfriends it was
very dramatic always dramatic
[Laughter]
amazing yeah we didn't there's like i
think anywhere you grew up like
there were the rites of passage chicago
ones right so there's like the museum of
science and industry and the aquarium
and stuff like that there were
definitely like the major hot spots in
chicago
yeah aquarium's a good trip too that
aquarium in chicago is amazing it's like
right on the lake and it's
gorgeous dc me and my friends skipped
the only time i like
really for real skipped school was we
went
into dc to see the unveiling of the baby
panda
oh i would have been there in two cents
yeah it was i mean it was first of all
this was the first panda
that we used the first baby panda that
we got so i'm british
dc went insane when we got a baby panda
they put the baby panda on all of the
metro cards
they had a city-wide like thing to name
the panda his name
ended up being taishan
[Laughter]
i must have expressed like deep deep
interest in that at the time because my
mom still sends me articles
about any dc panda stuff going on
they're new ones they're their arms
there are and the because the tragedy of
the dc panda situation is that
we are always the panda is always on
loan from china so we give our hearts to
this one panda
and then china comes and they take the
panda away
so we should not be like flying pandas
from
time absolutely not absolutely not
there's no way that's good for them i
mean we should just not have pandas
but if we're gonna have pandas we should
just keep them
at least don't make them fly don't put
them on a plane
taishan is from dc don't make him go to
china
he's from dupont circle exactly exactly
he's from the district
no oh god that's so crazy
uh all right let's talk about your
school so you already got into it a
little bit but the university of chicago
laboratory school sounds very fancy tell
me
what flavor of high school is this i
mean you said it's k-12 but what flavor
of
educational institution is this so the
like
nickname for it in chicago is you hi or
lab
okay but so okay so it's intended for
the kids of people affiliated with the
university of chicago so it's like
it's not on the campus but it's like
right next to it and it's all the same
architecture and blah blah
in hyde park and um so it's mostly kids
whose parents are professors or
doctors or whatever i wasn't um
my dad and grandpa also went to the
school so it was a family tradition
to go to this school um but most of my
friends parents were
at university of chicago in the law
school or the med school or
b-school or whatever so it's extremely
academic
like because all of their parents are
academics and it was just
really really nerdy yeah and it's run by
a call like a really prestigious
university
and it's all tied to like their calendar
so they start really late in the fall so
we would always start like weirdly late
um and we'd had ha we'd have to have the
same like breaks as them because it was
this
you know if the professors had a break
then their kids should have a break blah
blah so it was very tied to this college
it was cool because you had access to a
lot of like we would often go visit
cool classrooms or like you know and
have events
on the campus but it was it was weird
it's weird
so did was was there a way for people
like
outside people to be in the school or
did you have to have some kind of
connection
do you it was like i wonder what the
percentage is i feel like it's like 25
or something aren't affiliated and you
have to like apply and stuff i think
it's gotten
way harder um i feel like i just sort of
like
went and then my sister who's like four
years younger than me
had to like do one of those like
kindergarten interview type things or
they're like
what shape is this it's like that what
happens in those
what could you possibly be looking for
my friend's son just did it and then we
were like practicing he's four and he's
applying to or five and he's applying to
preschool stuff or kindergarten whatever
he is
and uh we were like practicing with him
because we're like he's gonna go into a
room with a strange adult and we have
no clue what he's gonna say like none
i just can't imagine as an adult
interviewing a child
in any serious way like it reminds me of
when i was watching like
the diane sawyer britney spears
interview and i'm like she's 22.
don't you feel silly talking to her like
i know
oh don't you feel odd that you're asking
a 22 year old about
her like like why her and her boyfriend
broke up
i know and we and jasper the little boy
he's
really funny and of course his like
dad's a comedian and stuff like that so
he like is way too
into like telling jokes and so recently
we were like he was talking about his
dad's an actor so he was like my dad's
an actor we were like what does your mom
do and he goes she works at sea world
and it's like she does not
[Laughter]
but it's like what if he just says that
in this interview
so it was like no clue what happened in
there and then he won't answer anything
afterwards it's like how'd it go he's
like good
so i don't know ah kids that's really
funny um okay
so you're at this school it has this
affiliation to the college
is there an expectation that you're
gonna go to university of chicago
afterwards
no though i i mean a lot of kids end up
going i wonder how many people from my
class i feel like it's like 15 or
something like that and i also there's a
whole thing of its free tuition
for kids whose parents are silly
affiliated with university or at least
extremely like discounted free tuition
to use chicago or free tuition to this
school
both the school and oh [ __ ]
so okay yeah so school is like a huge
perk of working at the university as
well totally
i think it's this big i think the reason
it exists is they're like if they're
trying to get a fancy professor or
whatever they're like your kid can go to
this nice school and it's right on the
campus and blah blah blah
i mean that is a nice that's that's no
joke as a
perk it really is i think there are
others similar
in other universities but yeah it's uh
it's really nice
for them okay so academically
how did that environment affect
teen amy so okay so here was my kind of
weird situation well so
it's in hyde park which is on the south
side of chicago
um and it's like it when i was a plot
you know when you were applying to
colleges and they sent those millions of
brochures to your house
the university of chicago had made this
brochure that was like this huge like
open up beautiful picture of the
university of chicago and they basically
had
juxtaposed it like it's next to downtown
like they had just deleted the miles and
miles in between
deleted this outside of chicago like you
have to take a major train to like
get downtown like for like 25 minutes so
i lived downtown
um so i lived and you know it in the
morning i feel like it took like 45
minutes in traffic in the morning
so i kind of lived sort of removed from
the school so i felt kind of
not like an outsider but like all my
friends were hanging in hyde park and i
was kind of more
um removed so i never quite felt like
as deeply a part of it as others did i
think
because a lot of kids were like you
lived so close to your pals and your
parents worked
together and you go to school together
and that kind of thing
but i was kind of we weren't affiliated
with university so it was a little bit
different for me
so were your friends like other people
who were
less like in it basically you guys like
formed an alliance a little bit yeah i
was friends with all than
with like the north side kids so it's
like
the kids that lived like like my best
friend since we were four
is this gal julia and her mom was a
doctor at university of chicago but they
lived
up by wrigley field so i think we felt i
mean we
fell in love at like the kindergarten
orientation
but the fact that we live both lived
north and could carpool and stuff was a
huge
thing um so i feel like that's such a
huge thing
for high school friendships too because
like my high school best friend megan
and my other really close high school
friend chelsea we all lived in the same
neighborhood totally so it's like it
just me it just
funnels you together because it's like
we were taking the same bus
together in the mornings we when it was
the weekend and your parents didn't want
to drive you anywhere like i could walk
to see them
when we started partying and getting
drunk we could all
covertly sneak away and meet up easily
like
it was all closer together totally but
then there's like the double-edged sword
of like
my mom would like want me to be friends
with the carpool people like the people
that were convenient and it was like
i don't like that kid you know it's like
i get that it's convenient for you but
like
this is hell for me yeah that's
i mean that's also a thing i mean going
from
k through 12 like once you get to high
school
are like all of the friendships and
everything your like social status
pretty much
set yeah it's that was the thing about
it was
like i had known most of them i mean
people came in and out
but like i've known muslims since i was
four like a lot of the people i
graduated with were in like
literal kindergarten class and it was
like 112 kids or something
so it just almost felt like there
weren't
as much like clicks like the jocks and
the mean girls and the
theater kids because it was just like
it's just like you know each individual
for so long yeah yeah and it's like you
they have been invited to your birthday
party in the past because everyone was
invited to everyone's birthday parties
in the past
and like yeah exactly and you know like
i honestly wanted to switch high schools
because i was just like
i can't like everyone had kissed
everyone by eighth grade
you know like it was just like there was
no one left
and where were you in the kissing were
you kissing were you
desperate to be kissed so i like
okay so my parents sometime in middle
school you know when like the earliest
kids start to kiss and your parents
somehow hear about it they were
basically like
you're not allowed like you're not
dating like no no no and that must have
been like fifth or sixth grade right
um and then they kind of just never
lifted that ban
like they never mentioned it again the
ban on kissing actually still stands
obviously you are not to be kissing
my dad does constant bits like we'll
call in the morning my boyfriend and i
and he'll be like
but you guys didn't like spend the night
together right like no possible way like
you guys are just met up for breakfast
right
but so the band just like they never
addressed it again so then i
sort of dated this guy from like 7th to
10th grade who was
upon reflection just my best friend and
also
he's gay turns out which i feel is a
rite of passage
it so is and oh i had a crush on a boy
in eighth grade
named michael and he and i really
i thought that like we were gonna be
together
and then he like went cold on me and i
didn't know why
and i remember i like really sadly
listened to a phantom planet song
and then i got to school and he was like
i am gay
and i was like absolutely
floored oh my god i mean it makes so
much sense now because it was like
we kissed for years and he never pushed
for more you know
he didn't come out until after college
though so this was like
it was uh yeah i always think of where
we grew up as like so liberal and
progressive and but i do they now i've
talked to friends who i'm like
a lot of people were really closeted um
yeah it was more in theory than in
practice i think
you know when we were in high school
like if you're talking like
early 2000s you know
it it was a hot button issue in a way
that i think
we forget and like it was 100
cool for someone to just openly be like
i don't think
people should be gay and like that was
actually a debate that was like
having out in public and i always am
like well i've been pro okay right
since i first started listening to emo
music
you know i mean like they like marriage
equality was only 2010 so
it's like then that's the year i
graduated high school so it's like
clearly it was i can't even i mean
yeah i i can't even imagine the struggle
like and i also think there's kind of a
weird dichotomy of like a place that
says it
but it but it's like that that's open
and liberal and cool but
it's not really happening in practice
you know yeah
and it's like to be that first kid who
is like
i'm openly gay at my school it's like
that's a big leap to have to take
for sure like with zero knowledge of
what it would be to come but i know
seriously
so yes i do think that dating a closeted
person is a rite of fact it doesn't mean
yeah so we like literally like seventh
grade i mean my parents definitely
knew but you know we like went to movies
all the time and that kind of thing um
and what my whole family used to go to
his family's passover seder so like they
all loved each other
um your parents were honestly probably
like this is amazing
this kid who's clearly gay
she's gonna be fine he's lovely
we can go to seder he's jewish he's
athletic this is unbelievable yeah his
parents were so smart
like oh unbelievable oh they're not
gonna do anything
yeah yeah i think that was pretty
perfect for them
um yeah so that was kind of my big
relationship that was him for a long
long long time which was perfect i mean
he was the best so
and was it like i mean i imagine that if
you're dating for that
long at a school that small it's like
you guys become
sort of an entity yourself as a couple
yeah yeah for sure and we went to prom
together
and like that was always a given and
stuff like that so it was like honestly
a very sweet
like supportive thing to have through
high school you know so when you guys
broke up in 10th grade was it like
it was kind of okay yeah we we remain we
were in this big group of
i you know i was such a tomboy like the
horrible kind of girl that was like i
get along better with
guys oh i said that so many times as a
teenager it's so
sad i mean yeah they wanted us to say
that
i know they did oh it's so free brittany
they wanted us to say
they incepted us i know they really did
and now like all that matters to me in
the world are my female friendship so
when i think about that it's like
so horrifying um but i we had this big
group of guy
pals danny and andy and nathaniel and
blah blah and it was uh
it all just was kind of okay and then we
still went to prom together and stuff so
it was just like
somehow it was okay yeah that's
interesting because you i mean
i guess that's the thing about high
school breakups is like they can go one
of two ways which is where you just 100
remain friends or it's like the most
dramatic thing that's ever happened to
anyone
i always chose to make it absolutely
not only i always chose to make it
something that not only affected me but
absolutely everyone around me
i think we kind of didn't have a choice
it was so small
you know also i was really bad at math
and he was really good at math and i
really relied on him
like yeah it was like hours long phone
calls every night like
helping me through math homework kind of
stuff it was like he helped me with math
and i helped
him with spanish and it was like a
beautiful symbiotic relationship
that's true and you can't i mean
especially in such an academically
rigorous environment
i know you don't want to fall behind
you can't burn those bridges
uh all right so let's talk extra
curriculars
you said you were you know uh were you
like sporty
let's let's talk about that soccer
soccer
soccer great i believe we have a soccer
photo that we can pull up
and this is uh i guess this must have
been this is actually on a brochure from
my high school which is horrific
wow but yeah that must have been a
soccer practice
i still so the thing you'll notice is i
look exactly the same
i've always i have never changed my hair
and it's always been my vibe
i like i've gone i've i've changed my
hairstyles at different times but i
always come back to this spot it always
returns to the mouth
yeah i think you like yeah there's like
a thing that's your right
like resting place i don't know exactly
exactly
now this soccer field we had like the
worst soccer field of any high school
when we would go play a school on
astroturf it was like oh my god this is
the fanciest thing in the world and now
this soccer field in this picture is
like so nice when i
took my boyfriend to go see like where i
grew up and blah blah and i was like
[ __ ] those people that's such a nice
soccer field
and how competitive was your team like
were
i mean like were you all good you're
really good so i got
i was really lucky that so i played at
school and then
outside of school that was my big i
played on like a travel team and all
this stuff
so school our team was so good when i
was in high school so we always used to
make it to the like final we always lost
in the final 16 of the state tournament
of the ihsa
the illinois high school whatever oh
that stuff gets so
i will it's um the one act play
competition in virginia is vhsl and i'll
never forget it i think i hsa a lot
um i have a lot of recurring dreams that
i forgot my um
shin guards that's like a big thing for
me right now that's so
interesting because i have recurring
dreams that i am about to perform and
play
at my high school and i don't know what
the play is about
and i've never heard of the play and i'm
trying and i'm always backstage at my
high school
trying to flip through the script but
it's like the it's this little tiny
light
and i can't read it and i'm trying to
memorize the script before the play
that's supposed to start in five minutes
it's horrible it's terrifying so is
yours always just
like are you back on your high school
field for that yeah i'm in the locker
room
i can't remember my combo to the locker
and i don't have my shin guards and i
don't have the red color socks and we
have a game
wow it is so crazy how the stress of
that like
buries so deep in your brain that as an
adult woman
like such a specific dream like that
i would come up it's really crazy it's
all the time it's like weekly
i have i have the play dream often
god it's so scary oh that's so bad
yeah soccer soccer was for real like
it was like school games this travel
team games that's where like my best
friends were from
um i my knees were really messed up so i
did a lot of physical therapy
i was i would go to this physical
therapy place near my house and it was
me
and like 60 year old men and it was like
what is
basically what science has learned is
girls shouldn't play
intense soccer in like middle school
because it just like
it's this whole thing of your glutes
don't develop and it [ __ ] your knees
and blah blah
but so it was like my kneecaps were
popping out i'd wear those huge knee
i wish i had a picture of that but i'd
wear knee braces on both knees
i feel like that's always a rite of
passage too it's like showing up to
school with like some kind of injury
totally a hundred percent you know what
i think about this a lot too
the basketball team wore suits on game
days
yes yes our basketball team and i think
our football team would wear a suit
it was so weird so you always knew when
the basketball team was playing because
they all showed up in a suit
it was bizarre i always was like they
look so cute in their little suits but i
don't want to admit it because they're
the football team
and they're my enemy catherine cohen
once said that when she sees someone in
a suit she's like oh he's in a play
so now because like if you're like in
midtown it's like why someone in a suit
they must be in a play they're gonna
play they have a basketball game
yeah maybe maybe it's game day
but yeah soccer was the big one and then
um
i got so i got really really
really involved in the obama campaign in
2008.
awesome let's actually i know that we
have photos of that so let's
pull those photos up yeah baby
um oh yeah wow
so open change baby
[Laughter]
so he is okay so president obama was our
senator
first our state senator then our senator
and his kids went to my school
wait sasha and malia went to my school
went to your school yeah have you
have you laid eyes upon them absolutely
oh my god they were like babies you know
how old were they when he got they were
like little
they were teeny tiny yeah yeah they were
little because i remember he was like
sasha malia
you're getting the puppy oh they were so
cute so my sister was only a little bit
my sister like had mutual friends with
malia and they
like so you know he was just kind of a
dad for a while
um and michelle was on the board of the
school and all sorts of stuff so they
were like
you know community presences so when he
announced he was running it was a
big thing for our community and like
also
you know i think we grew up the same
time like
bush clinton growing up during monica
lewinsky
and then bush it was like oh politicians
might not be so great
you know yeah and so then when this like
amazing dad from nearby
was running who was our senator it was
like oh this is
big you know so yeah it felt so
different at that time to like
see him and to just
i don't know and things were i mean the
politics of that time were so
crazy and i was i was like going to iraq
war protests at that time
and being like so to see this campaign
that literally said like hope and change
it was such a different vibe
insane um and we all knew he was like
amazing
you know um and so everyone just
like went nuts so my mom worked for the
campaign
and so i just got illinois was perfectly
situated of like clearly the
headquarters was there
and then also a ton of swing states
around
it so we would go to indiana or so we
started in iowa and i spent so much time
going every weekend and stuff and i
would organize kids from the school to
go and blah blah so it was
iowa and then we did indiana and the
primaries and then michigan wasn't far
and missouri wasn't far and so it was
just like perfect
for bussing everywhere yeah
um so i just like and then the bottom
picture is in
albuquerque new mexico where i went for
the summer
before the election and volunteered
there for the whole summer
okay how old were you then so i was like
16. okay yeah so you weren't even able
to vote for him at that
time i feel like i was also like because
i couldn't vote for him i was like i
have to make up for it
yeah i have to get more people to vote
for him see that
he was the first person that i was able
to vote for and i remember
it was like a big deal because in
virginia if you're gonna be 18 in the
election
you can vote in the primary they just
passed that here
oh really yeah um the things on you know
the
referendums on the ballot this last time
yeah it was actually really cool and i
think that it did
help kids like to care more
and as a result of that we had this
thing called candidates day
where all these local candidates came
and like
talked to us to try to get us to vote
for them because we could technically
all vote
and um it actually got extremely rowdy
and this woman jean-marie devilitis
davis
attacked a friend of mine because she
asked a question about abortion
oh my god um she was running for state
senate and
my friend asked a question about
abortion and my friend had been working
on her opponent's campaign and she said
i know who you are
for an adult right to a child she was
like i know who you
are and i know what you're trying to do
and everyone like basically turned on
her immediately because she was so rude
yeah which is interesting because i
don't think the community at large
liked me or my friends but i think they
were just like
how dare you come into our house and be
rude to us totally
so then everyone flipped out and started
chanting the name of her opponent chap
peterson
and um it got really bad and she like
laughed uh
in a half unbelievable that's amazing so
i mean i think if the mueller like it
was it was honestly like
high schoolers getting passionate about
politics is deeply nerdy but also like
so important
so and then when obama nominated rahm
emanuel to be his
chief of staff his seat was available
and so then i worked on a congressional
campaign
for this guy charlie whelan who was a
university of chicago professor who ran
for that and so i got really into like
local politics
um which was so did this like
you're so young and you're doing this
but did it make you feel
like very adult
i okay so because i grew up in like
literally downtown chicago
um i was always like you know i took the
train home alone you would take the
metra to the red line like
i was always super uh independent
um and my dad traveled a ton and stuff
like that and just
with all the soccer stuff too so i yeah
i was kind of like always just a little
like i was always like we've i flew to
new mexico myself and yeah with uh
like they put us up in supporter housing
which is like a volunteer lets you stay
in their guest room or whatever like
that
so with that it's like wha what was your
like
social life at that time when you're out
in new mexico because were there other
people your age or were you kind of
hanging out with older people
yeah yeah so my friend dan hornung who i
did all the obama stuff with
he and i went to new mexico together i
think that was probably why all of our
parents were okay with it was we
but we lived in separate houses and we
just like met at the office every day um
but i was like a fri you know i was like
a freak workhorse
type girl like i just loved canvassing
and making phone calls and stuff so that
summer there was
no socializing to be i saw dannon that
was it and i'd go home and read
you know yeah so you you truly just as a
teenager just went and did your work
yeah i i was so nerdy i like and also
still
but i just love to read so it was like i
would
you know that was the summer the last
twilight book came out
oh okay so like
pre-ordering it from the barnes and
noble in albuquerque and like going to
get it and being like i gotta go home
and go
weakness so was twilight a big
uh pop culture thing for you
i don't even think so but i loved do you
remember how big of a deal it was when
the harry potter books would come out
and
yes everyone you would go and wait at
midnight and you'd wear your
costume oh yeah i just loved that
like fanfare you know myself it's like
i'm searching for it anywhere
like what what is that you know there's
never fanfare about a book coming out my
dream is we all get
so excited and rowdy about what's coming
up i'm going to the midnight release of
notes from the bathroom
yeah baby yeah that's what i
wish so yeah i don't know so yeah i
wasn't
i i did not drink i did not do anything
i did not party
i was like a nerd big time
which i guess is why your parents why
your parents were like
yeah you can go because they knew
totally they were very trusting
almost to a fault maybe but um
no i was like big time goody two-shoes
bye
and were you like if you were around
that stuff would you be like scandalized
i was like not i i definitely like
judged people who like got really into
it but i would go
i could go to a party and see people
drinking and that didn't upset me i
definitely felt like oh i could drive
people home kind of thing like that made
me feel useful
and good you know yes because i like
until i made the switch from drinking to
not drinking other people drinking
scared me
so i was very scared by them and i was
like they could do anything
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally i was
definitely scared of girl i remember go
walking with my friends to the
homecoming dance and they
one of them had like a flask like in her
and i was like
they're gonna find that like they're
gonna pat you down at the door and
they're gonna find that and you're gonna
[ __ ] us all over you know yeah that's
just like
and we'll be sent to guantanamo bay
[Laughter]
do you know what happened yeah seriously
so i was so
scared about that and like in relation
to college and
you know i was terrified of all that
yeah they
well i would say high schools are very
good at doing a number on you about
making it seem like your college will
rescind your acceptance at any point
they drill that into your brain like if
your grades slip a little in the spring
like they can res yeah you better not
have a senior slump
yeah or else they'll take your recipe
they'll take it away
it's like why not just let people live i
know oh god yes
i was so scared at all times all right
let's take a look at some of these
like fill out the crew a little bit i
know we've got pictures of your friends
here yeah let's do the one with the
phone
first yeah okay so
who are we looking at here once again
you look exactly the same you have the
exact same hair
though i discovered teeth whitener which
is important but um this is my best
friend camille um
this was my like best soccer friend um
she has
a motorola razor which is so good
that's why i was so excited that you
included this picture because
i i feel like of all the burner phones
all the flip phones all the everything
the motorola razer
is the most iconic and the best
absolutely i mean that's kind of like
the image i think of when i think of old
phones yeah
that probably because she had literally
that one and i remember being so
jealous of it i never had a razor i had
like lots of weird chunky clunky guys
in this picture we are at a we're at a
luau in hawaii
we went to a soccer tournament in hawaii
and this was
so you can see a little bit she's
wearing like a puka shell necklace
which is amazing so and you so you go on
this soccer gym to hawaii and again it's
just like
no shenanigans you just purely play
soccer this is the big theme
no shenanigans we weren't allowed in the
water because
supposedly it could like drain your like
muscles so we were only allowed
in the ocean or the pool for 20 minutes
and this one girl maddie they caught her
in the water and she wasn't allowed to
start the game oh
no maddie so we went to hawaii and like
wouldn't
we weren't allowed to go in the ocean
that was insane
we're like 15. um it was insane and we
kept eating at like a wolfgang puck
express
it's just so dark oh god so it's like
you went to hawaii but
in a way that like did not celebrate at
all what
hawaii was no the soccer team was so
intense and so it was just like
that was all that mattered and it was
like come on we're 15 and we're in
hawaii i mean
honolulu i've been since and it's an
amazing city and that strip of
i think it's called waikiki or something
is like it's the worst
tourist trap or we kept going to
california pizza kitchen for all of our
meals i think about that all the time
it's so funny because it's like you
think they could have planned
one like and then for your last
dinner we'll do like a really nice
hawaiian
restaurant but no just california pizza
kitchen
and this was a luau that is like this
luau you buy expensive tickets too and
it's probably like the least
realistic um situation of all time
it was horrible um so yeah i went to
hawaii for this and just played soccer
and we lost
real bad it's like once you start losing
could you get in the ocean
like yeah it's like we're not doing well
like
let let we all want to join maddie in
the ocean we're in hawaii
maddie also got her her mom found out
she'd had her belly button pierced
because she she'd always uh
hit it but then her mom saw her in a
bathing suit and she saw it
that's not a lot of trouble this trip
yeah this trip uh
wrecked maddie's life but camille and i
were goodie two shoes but camille
you can see in this picture is wearing
like kind of some eyeliner
and i remember being like i can't
believe camille figured out makeup
[Laughter]
look at that gorgeous application
what was what what if anything was your
beauty regimen
in high school nothing like yeah to be
honest like
a little bit resent my mom for like
never telling me
anything like did you do makeup i did
makeup because i was like a scene kid
so i had like the thick eyeliner
on both eyes and then i would do like
crazy eyeshadow to match
my outfit and sometimes i would line
under my eye and one time i did that in
red and my drama teacher
said that i looked like i was bleeding
the first time the first time i ever had
makeup was when i went to get it done
for prom
wow so you were like tomboy
guys girl in that whole world i wore
i wore sports bras until
caught like college and then i like i
was the kind of girl who like got boobs
like
in a one-month span senior year of high
school like i had none and then it was
like
what just happened
and so i wore these like weird like you
know the first kind of bras you get like
they're like they were like nike sports
bras and i wore these same ones and then
i got like a couple bras before i went
to college and it was like a big deal
oh i remember like getting a bra at
limited too which like i had
i didn't even need one but i like bought
it and i i remember it was like powder
blue satin bra and i was just like
today's the day everything changed it
changes and then i would like put it on
and it was like falling off because i
have no boobs
sounds really sexy did you
um did you get a lot of commentary on
your
uh fantastical boob growth or i don't
know
i was so in just like strapping them
down you know
there was this girl especially for
soccer it all comes back to soccer
but like there was this girl who was two
years ahead of me
and she had huge boobs in high school
and she would go to the
trainer before and they would duct tape
her boobs down
oh my gosh cause it's like horrible like
also you chest trap a lot in soccer
and like if it hit your boobs especially
when they're like developing it hurts
so bad that actually hurt me to think
about to think about
i know oh my god for the men listening
getting hit on the boob really hurts
awesome they're sensitive
when they're growing they're really
sensitive if you're on your period
they're really sensitive
yeah so she would get she would go and
they would like tape them down to her
um and so then i was like i never i
would sleep purposely in a sports bra on
my chest to try to be like
not get boobs which really backfired but
it's okay now
see that's so funny to me because my i
was
absolutely convinced that the fact that
i did not have giant boobs
was something that was going to hinder
my entire life
uh everyone in my school was thinking
about this
we were talking about it with the
forefront of everyone's mind as far as i
was concerned
and as a result of that like i
remember every girl who had boobs me too
100 all of them yeah all of us change
into
uniforms for gym class yes wow we did
too
and it was like in that locker room you
knew exactly what was
happening with everybody's boobs like
100 it was only 50 girls
so it was like you knew like the exact
trajectory
of all of these boobs i actually i have
a traumatic locker room memory
which is that one time i was in the
locker room but i was behind the lockers
and no one could see me
and i overheard the popular girls
talking about me and they said that i
always wore
[ __ ] clothes but the teachers never
got
mad because i'm a weirdo oh my god
isn't that insane did you do the thing
where you slink away or did you like
come out
oh i did i did i first of all
direct it to the self-esteem
to the psyche forever forever
horrible i like like think about it to
this day
and so i just hit i like sat and i
waited
[ __ ] emily there is emily and
shanley and michelle
[Laughter]
i know i remember every single one of
those [ __ ]
this kid oliver said something to me
about since i overheard him saying
something about me being really loud
and that was like my self-esteem thing
too and so
for many many many years it's still
something i think about
i'm like i'm being so loud i'm being so
loud i'm being so loud like why am i
talking so much
it's i mean when someone gets you at
that
young of an age it's like even even if
it's just saying you're loud which like
who gives a [ __ ] no i know it just
strikes straight into you and it stays
there forever
oh god who i'm like maybe
i guess i do wear [ __ ] clothes i wear
less [ __ ] clothes now
now that i'm 30 my clothes are less
[ __ ] but
i used to wear pretty [ __ ] clothes
oh god they weren't wrong that was the
other thing that was harmful
is that they were actually not wrong and
i and i was wearing clothes that they
would have all gotten in trouble for
because they were like the desirable
women of the school
um so that was the other part of it that
was really mean like
another one that was very mean that i
was that my
my ex-boyfriend brian when we were going
through our very traumatic breakup which
as i said
i involved everyone around me um he said
that i smelled bad uh when i was on my
period
and that's true oh my god
there was a rumor that went around about
me that i was asexual
i think like someone must have just like
learned that term because i just like
wasn't like
like hooking up with you know like yeah
it was always like at every dance it was
like who hooked up with you know this is
like who hooked up with
blah blah and i never did any of that
and so there was a rumor that i was
asexual
and then they were like you know what
amy she's not
she's not making out at these dances
yeah what could the answer be
and so then yeah so and then that got in
my head and i was like am i
because you're not at a point where you
know yourself even well enough you know
no and i feel i mean i honestly feel
like now at gen z
it's like you could just be like i'm
asexual and everyone would be like i
respect that
totally which is beautiful but instead
now you're just like what does that mean
yeah i'm scared this is horrible is this
true
i know i know yeah those things will
really if it hits you at the right
moment
you'll never let go yeah and especially
if like like you were probably worried
because you weren't making out at the
dance and so you're like okay well
actually like the evidence that they've
presented is correct i'm not
doing this so does that mean i'm asexual
totally or does it just mean that i'm
like
really into soccer right now or my
parents told me
i was like five years ago and i never
asked again
what the rule was yeah or is my
boyfriend
gay yeah i don't know that's so funny
okay let's take a look at the other
picture you have of your friend here to
round
things out yeah oh yeah so this is
the one who i mentioned julia who is my
best friend since we are four
um and now she's a doctor it's so crazy
that like
that like people we grew up with are
like lawyers and doctors
and we're like i know here are some
jokes like i don't know
my friend megan who i mentioned before
is like fully a teacher and my friend
chelsea who also lived in my area is
like a full a geologist
and like she like knows science
yeah julia's a full doctor yeah in
chicago
i'm actually like a lot of them are
still in chicago like i'm
there are some people in new york and
stuff i have one really good friend
kelly who's out here and not like from
high school
and then oh so our you said your robes
were maroon too
yes yeah so our mascot was the maroons
that's what the university of chicago
thing is is just the color maroon maroon
i said i did not realize that that's the
mascot
yeah you know what is his
anthropomorphized form
there isn't one it's just there is none
no it's just like the maroons it's just
the color
it's like it's often like a maroon m
it's bizarre yeah so you don't have
anybody who runs on the field
no so i'm so so glad to get to college
and be like a tiger
[Laughter]
so yeah let's briefly uh go through that
journey so this friend ended up a doctor
how did you go from here you're playing
soccer
you're you know focused on that how do
you go from here to
working in television editing a book
all of that well so i i was always
really into comedy
um because i also grew up near second
city in chicago so
i was obsessed with gilda radner and
just like loved comedy
and also like there was so much good
improv and stuff in chicago
so i started i always took classes at
second city and then
senior year of high school i got really
into
improv stuff so i started doing classes
and stuff um and then did that through
college and blah blah but yeah so
as soon as my knees fell apart and i
couldn't play soccer as well anymore
i was like gotta find something else
that's not as physically demanding
and we landed on improv yeah exactly
it's so funny because if you really look
at them
like the things that are important to my
dad are soccer and comedy and i was just
like okay
that's fine i'll do it okay
i love you he was like the really
intense
dad on the sidelines screaming he had to
become a referee
because he was so intense and if he was
a ref he couldn't do that
you know he had to set a boundary for
himself of being the brother
yeah insane it was horrible he was uh
yeah
i think that has been an incident where
he lost us sportsmanship points
oh no oh no
that's uh that's so funny uh
do you remember uh any big like
scandals from your high school any major
rumors
apart from you being asexual yeah um
yeah that was my fun rumor um there was
definitely a time where they were like
they found a used condom on the floor of
the dance
oh no so nasty
so like the dance i assume everyone's
kind of looked similar but it was always
like everyone in like a group
of like grinding or whatever and then
like they said they found a condom
it was so gross
oh god because i also feel like
i just feel like that condom was
like used for a hand job like i don't
think that it was
even sex i think that i think
my image that comes to my mind is that a
boy
arrived maybe with a condom on his penis
to come like that is amazing and then
the
the group the class ahead of me did you
guys do a senior prank
we like no we didn't but there was
always talk of
that happening in the past or whatever
yeah this
our class didn't really ultimately i
don't think but the seniors ahead of me
like like did something horrible to the
library
like they like like i don't remember
what it was like i think they set
something on fire and then
and then the like sprinklers had to go
on and then
like the books were ruined and it was
like bad like the height library had to
like be rebuilt
and i remember getting like a crazy
lecture in the
cafeteria it was like this is pranks are
not
setting the library on fire no
it was fire or like water but something
that ruined like a lot of the books
um yeah terrific yeah of course as a
reader i was like this is not
fair the library not the library
also coincidentally where i ate lunch
alone so i was like that's my place
that was a direct hit on you i know
seriously it might have been me
i never thought about that oh god we're
going to teach this girl not to make out
at the dances
[Laughter]
we're going to flutter out
i should check what i got to ask someone
what that was
yeah it was fire or water something like
something i do like that it's
just like something terrible has
happened to the library
i know i mean it was such a small school
that stuff traveled i know everyone knew
stuff i got asked to prom my junior year
a senior
asked me to prom my junior year big deal
big big huge
of course a boy on the boys soccer team
and um he made
a build-a-bear do a rebuild-a-bear oh my
god that
to make a build-a-bear is like the
highest
honor you could give someone
yeah so he made this bill to where it
was like wearing a suit and if you
pressed its
hand it said like will you go to prom
with me amy did you guys do like prom
poses yes yeah yes there weren't like
enormous ones but that was like and he
but he told people he was gonna do it
and so he did it in the cafeteria and
people were like waiting to watch
and that was horrific to me i did not
like that kind of attention
no no i think that a really
toxic thing that has been told to men is
that
um women want you to ask them out in
public
in front of everyone and that is not
correct they do not want that i mean
some do
but they're crazy and
and that's all of tick-tock and they can
have that area for themselves
yes yes oh god oh
the build-a-bear ask is so huge i know
it was huge
i it was like and then i looked up and i
saw that everyone was watching
and it was horrible but the build-a-bear
was very sweet
i mean it was very sweet my high school
boyfriend the one who i
who did ultimately uh break my heart by
saying i smell bad on my period
um by posting that on myspace actually
oh my god that's insane
it listened it was a rough time oh my
god like i said
i made sure that all of my breakups were
as dramatic as possible
that should be you can't just go
silently out of that
well i i had fired some shots first
i'm not i'm i'm not innocent
in the debacle that took place there
um but he did yes ultimately posted my
space comment that said i smelled about
on my period
but oh my god
before doing that um he did give me a
build-a-bear
in which he sang evermore
because that was our song by the way
didn't it aren't they mad at taylor
swift
are the foo fighters mad at him because
of she has a song called evermore now
but hers is an album
[Laughter]
no no protect taylor no no no
i don't need the foo fighters to be
fighting with taylor swift i also kind
of made it up
i might have made that up who does
that's very sweet how much of the song
was it how much could you fit on one of
those things
i think it was he maxed out what could
be something
[Laughter]
but you know the thing about that is he
was standing in the build build-a-bear
workshop
singing singing what were those like
little
microchips or whatever they were yes he
did he sung
it he sung it at the builder bear
workshop um so it's just it's just
interesting to
see what he really thought of me when
actually
you know a couple months ago you're
singing my praises at a build-a-bear
so suddenly we're saying some pretty
rude stuff on my space brian
oh my god yeah there was a big thing
it was there is build-a-bear still i
have no idea i have no idea
not it it's not a part of my life
anymore i want
i someone please write in and tell me if
build-a-bear
survived the early 2000s or the pandemic
do we know are people going to build a
bear
all right amy i think that is the
perfect place for us to round
this out with our last question yeah
which is if you could talk to teen amy
today
what would you tell her oh i ended up
um dating a guy who i met senior year
through junior year of college long
distance
and i would tell her don't do that
don't do that you gotta go to college
and kiss uh everybody
i like no one should go to college in a
long distance relationship
i firmly believe that that's fantastic
advice for any young people listening to
the pod
yeah don't do it it's just a dessert
okay wow i'm just getting note from our
producer claudia that build-a-bear
is still active it has survived the
death of the mall
it has survived a global pandemic
build-a-bear still going strong oh we
may
need to look into that that's incredible
you need let's do
the roast of your teenage self build a
bear build a bear i mean
let's game stop build a bear you know
what i mean
i don't know how to do that but maybe
some of the people
maybe some of the people who watch on
youtube know how to do that let's
game stop build-a-bear that's brilliant
all right um so any more advice for teen
amy
kiss more people in college um
wear your knee braces babe they're ho
they're important
don't go long distance and protect your
knees that's excellent advice that's
excellent advice for anybody
i've heard other guests give like actual
good advice so i'm embarrassed no that's
beautiful
okay i like for the advice to run the
gamut of practical
to emotional okay
a good guy all right this is an amazing
episode amy everyone listening
uh get notes from the bathroom line
it'll be available once this episode
comes out
all the places that you can buy books
elise's piece is amazing skip go
straight to elise's
it is about uh i will say that it is
about an often discussed topic on this
podcast which is seth cohen
on the oc so go check it out uh i also
do
i read it in the audiobook if you're an
audiobook person
and uh for everybody listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you